the search for missing Malaysian flight
mh370 is the biggest in aviation history
thousands of men and women scouring
millions of square miles looking for a
needle in a haystack even with some of
the most sophisticated search and rescue
equipment available finding the missing
plane has been tough but the biggest
breakthrough didn't happen in the
southern Indian Ocean it happened here
on the old Street round of house in the
hustle and the bustle of the East End of
London in an unremarkable building
filled with people doing remarkable
things inmarsat has been in the
satellite business since 1979 and went
public in 2005 the curry has 10
operational communication satellites
that are used by everything from ships
two planes to broadcasters what they do
here really is rocket science but
figuring out what happened to mh370
requires some radical thinking a week of
hard work and lots of pizza the way they
did that was with this
no not that racing car but the Doppler
effect which describes how signal
frequency changes over distance in the
racing class case that sound but in this
case it was pings between the satellites
and the aircraft and what that allowed
the engineers here inmarsat to do was
not only figure out the corridors in
which the aircraft could have been
operating but more critically the
direction of travel down here into the
southern Indian Ocean the hope now is
that tangible evidence will be found
that will actually explain what really
happened but whatever that is narrowing
the search area will have proved pivotal
whether or not this breakthrough has any
meaningful impact on inmarsat bottom
line remains to be seen but one thing is
for certain and that is that this area
of London has once again secured its
reputation as a home and a hub for some
truly innovative companies